we'll
try something else
okay g3 then
no more of this grenfell nonsense
he's played the symmetric symmetrical
english quite a bit
himself as white but then he plays with
d3 and queen e2 which
i think he basically invented himself
which is a pretty good line
yeah this is something
that i played there are many moves you
can play here
let's just go for this one this i played
again so in a blitz game once
and the game will draw on but i feel
like i was a little bit better in the
i game now you're supposed to
push
and then you go b3
[Music]
hmm yeah this is
quite possible i guess
obviously he was just gonna make the
most active move
there's no doubt about that okay i'll
take an e6
then i'll wait a sec
wait a sec i thought bishop six
knight g5 was good for me but fe 6
this one is not so clear perhaps
okay
how about night i'll go knight e4 yeah
why not if he takes an a1
i take an a1 at least have a threat of
knight f6
if you take some on c4
i guess bishop a five
followed by queen d6 maybe
bishop a1 or k1 or knight f5
at least i can go queen c5 and decent
compensation
this is a mess this is a total mess
bishop b7 now i'm hoping that knight g5
is going to be really good
yes detecting c4 very
logical and quite expected
rook c1 is maybe not insane
so many choices if when
why what
um
okay we'll take an f5
queen d6 and then take back on a1
i feel like if he goes for yeah this
standard line that i mentioned with uh
takes and knight f5 or knight five
immediately uh
and i capture on c5 we exchange
queens cb3 ab3
um i feel like i have excellent
compensation there
95 is coming next
and his bishop is really really awful
probably my compensation is just enough
for equality but it doesn't seem like
i'm
i'm running a risk here
yeah it's very logical but i
i am getting some threats of bishop f1
now
there's knight c6
she's evidently not scared of
should it be rookie eight
then there's 94.
it looks very tempting
yeah knight e4 i got g4
and knight d6 on the cards
look it's looking quite promising
okay g4
oh what am i doing i can just take the
bishop immediately like
97 and then take c8
why is that trying to to make the other
thing work
so this is easy enough
like it's not easy in terms of winning
the game for sure
there's still a bunch of work to do
there but
in order to gain a serious advantage
it's easy
okay i'll go rotate one i think
oh this one
okay i don't see it for the moment so
i'll just call this bluff
yeah g5 that was
sort of expected
okay we'll go rook a7
it's knight h4 king h3
it looks like i'm doing well rook f1
there's knight f5
f7 and then i can take on g5
beat the knight and here as well
i'm capturing f7 after a check and
i'm capturing g5 after this check okay
take g5
what am i missing here
i'm using this
yeah knight of three knight of three
i don't have a good reply god i have to
do that anyway
probably rick h2 there's king g3
and here you know what i'll go king
i'll go king here first
we'll go take one pawn
[Music]
push i should be winning
his only hope is e5 and then some sort
of stalemate
here i think i'm just meeting him kg6
next
oh he still has this
so annoying
how do i win now okay
check
c5 this doesn't make a lot of sense
okay we take
this has become a complete mess
complete and utter mess
i'm actually not winning this
[Music]
it's unbelievable just unbelievable
okay well done good good defense somehow
i just got so casual there
i got so casual and then i couldn't
i couldn't speed up so what was
this like knight f6 king f8 e4 knight f1
knight goes to e3 at this moment i could
just
push g5 of like
yeah king g5 i thought it was just
mating also key e5 is just winning
no goods no good no good